When Amy looks herself up at the library,
she discovers that a website has been set
up in an effort to find her.
The URL is findamazingamy.com,
and if you visit that site it takes you to
the studio’s website, but if you look at an
archived version of the page from 2014 when the
movie came out, you get something a little more
interesting.
And it seems that it’s not
too different from the main screen on the Blu-ray.
However there are many other webpages, TV
screens, and billboards we can scrape for
information as well as other Things You might have
Missed, so stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Hunt a Killer.
“But CZ,
Gone Girl isn’t a horror movie, you’re
not allowed to cover it.”
OK, if Gone Girl isn’t a horror movie,
explain why I can’t show any of this scene.
So with that settled, let’s
start looking for clues.
“Well, we have our first clue.”
When Nick enters the bar on the morning of Amy’s
disappearance, he’s holding the game, Mastermind.
In the novel, Nick and Margot had this thing where
they’d bring over old board games and toys from
their childhood home to help pass the time at
the bar. Although we don’t know it yet, perhaps
Mastermind is symbolic of his wife masterminding
a plan to get back at him for his infidelity.
There are other games and books in
the stack that seem to represent things
that would eventually happen in
the story. There’s Emergency!
Widowmaker…
“Missouri has the death penalty.”
Sex escort.
“I don't know I'd have to check my red panty inventory.”
Jailbait…
“How old is she?”
“She’s in her early 20s.”
Let’s Make A Deal…
“This is why I
have a $100,000 retainer, I win the unwinnable cases.”
“A hundred thousand
dollars?”
“We’ll figure something out.”
The Hot Seat…
*sits* “Nick Dunn, you’re probably the most
***ed man in America right now.” “I probably am.”
There’s also a miniature Tom Sawyer riverboat,
to go along with the journal page about when
Amy first met Nick and he told her he’s
from the childhood home of Mark Twain,
the author who created Tom Sawyer and Huckleberry
Finn. Tom Sawyer famously attended his own funeral
after his family thought him to be dead,
which is nearly what happens with Amy,
watching her family search for her after
her disappearance and presumed death.
When Nick doesn’t feel like talking,
his sister offers to distract him with
excruciatingly mundane stories. It
isn’t ever mentioned in the movie,
but in the book, telling these stories is a game
that Nick and Go play, inspired by their mom,
“who had a habit of telling such
outrageously mundane, endless stories.”
There are other instances of sort of inside
jokes for those who have read the book,
like in the scene where Nick first meets Amy and
asks “who are you?” and she gives him
a variety of multiple choice answers.
“A. I am an award—winning scrimshander. B. I
am a moderately influential warlord. C. I write
personality quizzes for magazines.”
“I’m gonna go with C.”
When we’re reading through
Amy’s diary entries in the book,
this is something she does all
the time with her audience as a
“what do you think I did?” or “one of
the following is what actually happened.”
By the way, when we see Amy writing
the journal entries, you may notice
all of the different pens she used, evidence
that she’s faking the entire journal by using
different pens to make it look like the
entries were written on different days.
Then there’s the Ellen Abbott segment where
the prominent talk show host is analysing
Nick’s life and makes the suggestion that
he and his sister are “disturbingly close.”
“I didn’t use the I-word, I said
you two were extremely close.”
Ellen never makes this insinuation in the book,
but rather, it was a rumor that went around about
Nick and Go when they were in high school, a part
of Nick’s life that is never covered in the movie.
There are a ton of nods to the book in
this scene where police discover Amy’s
diary. Detective Boney flips through the
pages and if you pause you can see little
snippets of Amy's writing. It seems as if
the ENTIRETY of Amy’s journal entries
in the novel have been copied down
into this journal by hand and more.
It reminds me of the last episode of Things
You Missed, where I covered another movie
directed by David Fincher, Zodiac, where I
mentioned that every newspaper on the set was
that day’s paper printed in full. So I have
no doubt that Amy’s entire diary is here.
By the way, there is a connection to Zodiac
here. At the end of my Zodiac episode I
mentioned that I’d be closing the Zodiac
case and moving on to the Amy Dunne case,
and Zodiac ended with this survivor, Mike
Mageau, identifying this suspect as The Zodiac.
Well, as the missing person investigation gets
underway in Gone Girl, the same actor who played
the young version of Mike Mageau also plays
the police officer who finds the first clue.
There are other David Fincher movie
callbacks too. When Go is watching
Noelle Hawthorne’s interview on Ellen Abbott,
she’s drinking a glass of wine. The brand is
Norton. Edward Norton plays the main
character from Fincher’s Fight Club.
Side note: strange choice of beverage
to accompany your cereal and milk.
In the book, Amy takes out
Desi with a kitchen knife. So
why in the movie has it been changed to a
box cutter? The only reason I can think of,
is to reference the most iconic
scene of David Fincher’s Se7en.
And finally, while Detective
Boney is reading the Amy diary,
her partner asks, “you reading that
diary again? You know how it ends?”
...to which she replies, “it interests me,”
the same exact line used by a character
named Lisbeth when she goes through
some documents related to a murder
case in Fincher’s previous movie,
The Girl With The Dragon Tattoo.
"Why would a young lady like you want to know about such an awful m*rder?"
"It interests me."
Knowing Fincher, everything he does
is very deliberate, and we can look
to the background details of many other Gone
Girl scenes for even more Things You Missed.
The season we've been waiting
for all year has finally arrived,
and there's been a lot of disappointment in
the horror community because haunted houses,
Halloween parties and horror movie
premieres have all fallen victim
to COVID-19. Many of us are left wondering how
we'll celebrate our favorite holiday this year,
and one of the coolest things I've found
is Hunt a Killer's new Blair Witch game.
It's basically a subscription box that puts
you in the center of a new horror mystery
taking place in the universe of one of the
greatest found-footage movies of all time:
The Blair Witch Project. Each season consists
of 6 episodes. When you open the box you'll
receive your case file, which consists of
realistic evidence, we're talking journals,
police reports, maps and other documents
that will help you solve the mystery of
Black Hills Forest. If I could compare to
anything, I'd say it really has the feeling
of an escape room. It's very hands on, and it
makes you a character in the story. There are
certain parts where you make a revelation,
that's genuinely just creepy and unsettling.
Right now, just for Things You Missed viewers
you can go to Hunt a Killer dot com slash
CZsWorld and use code: CZsWorld, for 20% off
your first box. Again, make sure to use code:
CZsWorld for a 20% discount and
to show your support for the show.
Can you survive the curse of The Blair Witch?
Fincher is a master of
storytelling in the subtext,
and throughout the movie there are many
brilliant examples, that you may not have
thought about while watching. When Nick and
Go are playing The Game of LIFE in The Bar,
he adds a wife to his car, but never adds
a child, this plays into the whole dispute
about Amy supposedly wanting a child, then
not wanting one, then wanting one again.
In their living room, there’s a box from a
brand called Piranesi. As far as I can tell,
this isn’t a real brand, it’s likely a
reference to the Italian artist Piranesi,
who was known for his etchings of fictitious
and atmospheric prisons. The box is found
right next to the staged crime scene designed
by Amy to get Nick thrown in prison, or worse.
As Nick takes the two detectives through the crime
scene, he quickly moves on from the
kitchen to show them the next room,
but Boney notices the blood splatter on the
backsplash. This makes Nick look very suspicious.
Amy’s a writer, but her degree is in psychology,
again, setting up her mastermind of a plan.
In the flashback at the release event for the new Amazing Amy book,
this guy is way too delighted to rub it
in Amy’s face that she’s not married.
“Because it’s my understanding
you are not married.”
Not counting that as a Thing You
Missed. I just find it funny.
The flashback of Amy and Nick’s kiss
cuts directly to Nick getting his cheek
swabbed because he’s suspected
of Amy’s murder. Brilliant cut.
In another flashback, when Amy and Nick
are doing the second anniversary treasure hunt at the library,
we see a book facing the camera. Not sure if
it says Twin or Twain, but either way it’s
relevant. Nick is part of a set of twins living
in the land of Mark Twain, I’m counting it.
I’m not sure how there’s a secret area of
this library that only they know about, but
moving on… McCaulay Culkin has a cameo for some
reason, it’s the kid from Home Alone. There’s a
theory that he’s a young John Kramer. No, I don’t
actually know if that’s him but it’s pretty funny.
OK, moving onto a real one, the police show
Nick pictures of Amy with Noelle Hawthorne,
because Nick previously claimed
that she wasn’t friends with Amy.
Amy only befriended her as part of her plan, and
in one of these photos, they’re seen together at
Andy’s Frozen Custard. I recognize it because we
used to go there after baseball games sometimes.
I think this fits in with the idea that Amy
is taking Nick on a tour of shame with her
treasure hunt. All of the clues were at places
that Nick was together with his mistress, Andie,
so this is another secret way of her telling
Nick, this is because of Andie. There’s also
something poetic about the fact that Amazing
Amy from the children’s books ends up with a
guy named Able Andy, and the real Amy ends up with
a guy who cheats on her with a girl named Andie.
At one point, the police ask
what Amy does with her time,
and he tells them she’s always got a book
in her hand. We later find that to be
kind of true, little does Nick know, she’s
actually researching her revenge on him.
Later on, she’s checking in to see how everything
panned out and she decides to look up Ellen Abbott
on Google to see if she’s covered Nick on
her show yet. After she types the letters:
E-L, one of the autocomplete suggestions
is “Eliminate Your Spouse in Three Easy
Steps.” And at that moment, she felt very
stupid. She could have done it in 3 steps,
but instead she over complicated
the process to hundreds of steps.
Meanwhile, Nick is headed to the airport to go
meet with Tanner Bolt, and there’s a billboard
for Sharon Schieber, the other big talk show
host in this universe, and as Nick walks by it,
Sharon turns almost as if to look at him -- it’s
like she’s eyeing him as a potential big story
to have on her show, and he would eventually
go on that show under Bolt’s recommendation.
You know, I could probably forgive Nick
killing his wife, and I could maybe
even forgive him cheating on her, but this isjust
unforgivable Nick, you’ve just lost my sympathy.
But right before the big Sharon Shieber
interview, there’s a great moment that shows
how far Nick has come as a character. Early on he
was criticized for cracking a nervous smile at the
press conference for his missing wife, but by this
point in the story he’s become much more careful.
Sharon gives him this huge smile at the start of
the interview, and his instinct is to smile back,
but he fights it and remains stoic. It’s a minor
detail, but it’s very powerful.
Oftentimes in Things You Missed episodes,
we will find that taking a closer look
whenever we’re looking at text will yield
some good old crew-reference easter eggs.
There are a good amount of them, so
I’m gonna go through them all quickly.
The Amazing Amy book illustrations by Kirk Van
Wormer, he’s part of Gone Girl’s art department.
If you pause on the directory of the building
where Tanner Bolt’s Law Office is you’ll see
Bolanowski Labs -- a reference to Special
Effects Coordinator Rob Bolanowski;
Bradford Ralston Insurance Brokers, named
after sound utility man Bradford Ralston;
Bozeman and Associates, named after Gary
Bozeman of the transportation department;
Curtis Childers and (something, you can’t make
the rest of it out), but Curtis Childers is
credited as a construction foreman; Dingle
and George Brothers references three people,
Robert Dingle, TyRee Dingle and
Brett George, they all worked in
the transportation department. There
may be others like Brown or Campbell,
but those are pretty common names, I’m gonna move
on to some more references that I’m sure about.
Like the credits of the Ellen Abbott show
where you’ll see that Ellen Abbott’s editor
is William Peake -- in the Gone
Girl credits there’s a Billy Peake
who was an assistant editor. Ellen’s art
directors are Tyler Nelson and Eric Weidt,
an assistant editor and visual effects
artist on Gone Girl respectively.
And lastly, Ellen Abbott’s makeup
department has a Chad Peter and Lyla Bol.
Chad is Gone Girl’s visual effect compositor,
Lyla Bol I believe is the wife of Gone Girl’s
post-production coordinator Randall James Bol,
the two worked together on the second Lego
movie, which is Lyla’s only credit so far.
At the beginning of this video, I mentioned that
the URL, findamazingamy.com, actually worked at
one time, so I was curious about the phone numbers
as well. So I decided: I’m gonna call them.
Here are a few more things I love
about Hunt a Killer's Blair Witch box.
The story. As soon as I started
looking over the evidence,
I immediately got hooked on it. You start
to learn who the major characters are,
gain an understanding of the town, and you
really become invested in solving the case.
This one follows a woman named Rosemary
Kent, who lives on the edge the infamous
Black Hills Forest, and she needs our
help to find her missing son, Liam.
The lore is really good too. This isn't just
a generic game of Clue with a Blair Witch logo
slapped on it. They actually partnered with
Lionsgate to make something that works within
the Blair Witch universe. Everything they send
you feels like it belongs in a Blair Witch movie.
So everything feels very immersive. If you
loved Things You Missed, you'll love looking
out for those little clues, it's a great
feeling whenever you unlock a new discovery.
It's perfect way to get creeped out
whether you're stuck at home alone,
or if you want to team up with
a partner or roommate, and
unlike most ARGs, you're not just
staring at a screen the whole time.
You're gonna be getting a 20% discount
using my link, which you can find in the
description. That's Hunt a Killer dot com slash
CZsWorld and use code: CZsWorld for 20% off.
Unfortunately, when you try to call the
phone numbers seen on screen in Gone Girl,
you won’t have much more luck than you would
trying to get to the findamazingamy website.
But, upon looking it up, I found that calling
the Amy tipline used to result in a recorded
message of someone reading a passage of
the novel in a creepy monotone voice.
If anyone has this recording, please upload
it, I’m interested in hearing what it was.
But on that note, I have a passage of my own to
read, and it leads into the next Thing You Missed.
“I am so lucky, this is my husband, this
man will be the father of my children.
We’ll all be so happy . But I may
be wrong, I may be very wrong.”
This is one of several instances in
Amy’s diary where she considers herself
“lucky” to be with Nick, and the movie seems to
touch on the theme of luck quite a few times.
First, there’s the old saying “luck
of the Irish.” Let’s roll that clip.
“Well the Irish prince
graces us with his presence.
His majesty prefers not to be moistened.”
But that’s not all. Amy’s middle name, as
seen on her degree, is Wexford. Wexford is
the name of a town in Ireland. This
part of her name isn’t in the book.
When Amy meets up with Desi Collings, it’s
at a casino. Winning money at a casino is
luck of the draw. And at that casino,
someone recognizes her and asks if she’s
one of the Nolan Sisters. The Nolan Sisters
are the Irish pop group known for their hit,
"I'm in the mood for dancing.”
In the book, this man asks if
she’s part of the Enloe family,
so there must be some reason for this change,
right? Like I said, when Fincher does something,
you can bet there’s a reason for it.
The existence of the casino is also teased really early on, when we first see the find Amy billboard.
And the name, The Riverboat Casino, ties back into the Tom Sawyer thing that I mentioned earlier.
And remember when I brought up Margot's strange choice of breakfast options?
Where she’s drinking red wine with her cereal?
Well, I brought up the brand of the wine,
now let’s take a look at the milk. It’s Clover.
A seven leaf clover is considered lucky.
“Holy camole. A seven leaf clover!”
The movie ends as it began, but if we compare the
shots from the beginning of the movie to the end
we see how things have changed. How a quiet
little neighborhood was overtaken by a media
circus. And how Nick, who once daydreamed
about cracking his wife’s skull open,
now flinches at the simple
action of her turning her head.
Click the playlist on the left to see my
entire collection of Things You Missed
episodes on David Fincher movies, and let
me know in the comments if there are any
directors or franchises you’d like to see me
cover next. Until then, if you love horror,
remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, RING the deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one. Assuming we stay inside.